hume's it looks at the friendship of the
two allied leaders whose paths
intersected on the eve of World War two
this program from the english-speaking
Union in Washington DC runs an hour
we're here tonight to celebrate the
publication of a new book it's a book
called Eisenhower and Churchill the
partnership that saved the world and
it's a great honor to be able to
introduce the person who will introduce
the speaker who is the author of this
book I refer to Susan Eisenhower
granddaughter of the eisenhower referred
to in the book now this is a book that
has a forward by Susan's brother David
so the Eisenhower connections are deep
and very important
I first met Susan I believe it was in
1986 about 15 years ago and during the
year since then she's become one of my
dearest and most treasured friends and
she will be talking among other things
about a special relationship between two
men that epitomizes in a lot of ways the
special relationship between two nations
that of course is the subject of the
book susan is head of the Eisenhower
world affairs Institute she is the
author of op-ed pieces in the New York
Times The Washington Post and numerous
other periodicals about three weeks ago
she spoke at the National Press Club
about a topic that in many ways she and
her husband role sagdeyev anticipated
with a book they co-authored entitled
Islam and Central Asia
Susan is also the author of two books
under her own name
the first was entitled breaking free and
it was about the relationship between
the granddaughter of an American
president and a rocket scientist in the
Soviet Union who was part of the Supreme
Soviet
and who was one of Gorbachev's chief
arms negotiators and when this
relationship led to a marriage
one American newsman commented that it
was the clearest sign to date that the
Cold War was over susan has also written
a biography of her grandmother it's
entitled mrs. Ike and it's now my great
pleasure to introduce her Susan
John thank you for that generous
introduction it's really a very great
pleasure for me to be here this evening
to introduce Jamie Humes and I know that
we've got a great treat in store for us
I had the great pleasure of having an
opportunity to look at the book and to
begin reading it and I have to say that
I think it's a book that makes an
enormous contribution to this very
interesting relationship not only
between two men but of course as John
says a relationship that also symbolizes
the friendship between two countries I
thought also that there were some
fascinating parallels between these two
men who are really very very different
indeed of course a man who was born at
Blenheim Palace compared with someone
who was born on in what we used to call
him the Eisenhower family the wrong side
of the railroad tracks and Abilene
Kansas and you have to go to Abilene
Kansas to know that there really is a
wrong side of the railroad tracks it
goes right through town I thought it was
fascinating for instance that there were
despite these differences of some
enormous Lee interesting parallels
apparently they were two men who were
the first heads of state to own their
own pilots licenses both of them being
adventures in their own right both both
of them I thought and this is
extraordinarily interesting for me
because I wrote about it in my book mrs.
Ike but both men actually lost young
children in the very same year in 1921
during the prime of their lives in their
30s both felt a disconnection from the
great events of the day
Churchill was in political exile
Eisenhower was in a sense and in the
backwater of his profession coaching
football teams at Camp meat and other
tasks like this and I think both of them
had a very strong premonition as my
brother points out in his introduction
about the coming war both of them
preparing in their own way for the time
that was coming hmm I think
the book is beautifully balanced in the
sense that there is of course Churchill
the visionary in the orator and
Eisenhower the implementer of this
policy during the war and of course the
period after World War two when
Eisenhower was at NATO and and Churchill
was still the most dominant figure on
the international scene and then of
course later is the relationship and our
relationship between the United States
and Britain changed as World War two
brought America into its position as a
major superpower and as the relationship
between those two countries changed and
so I think this book is a real gem and
it gives me tremendous pleasure to
introduce Jamie Hume the author he is
the rise professor of language and
leadership at the University of Southern
Colorado he's the author of numerous
books in fact one specifically on
Churchill called the wit and wisdom of
Winston Churchill and I think it's
probably the enormous contribution he
has played to the literary community his
interpretations of Churchill that
actually won him the Order of the
British Empire in 1990 for being an
American citizen I would say that's
quite an extraordinary recognition he's
also been elected fellow of the Royal
Society of Arts and so you have in Jamie
Hume one of the individuals that
characterizes this wonderful state of
mind as kind of mid-atlantic state of
mind that really is that place where our
two countries meet and share a very
special destiny so it's my pleasure to
introduce to Jamie Hughes
Thank You Susan wherever Susan is you
see reflected and manifested the
personality and charm of her grandfather
On January 12 1965 the London Times
had this editorial in comment to the
slippage into a coma by Sir Winston
Churchill no one can predict when the
end will come but death is uncertain
there are one man had predicted on three
occasions when Churchill would die
Churchill himself he said he would die
on the anniversary of his father's death
and indeed on January 24th at 8 o'clock
in the morning so Winston Churchill died
the 70th anniversary to the very day to
the very hour to the very minute now in
Palm Springs where General Eisenhower is
vacationing he's not surprised by the
news but he is surprised at the Times LA
Times report that Lyndon Johnson had not
put him on the delegation well
delegation no delegation he was
determined to say farewell to his old
friend on the plane ride over memories
washed through his head of Churchill and
his words echoed
of their experiences together yes Susan
pointed out one was born in a palace the
other actually in a railroad track in
Texas but they had such commonalities
eyes and I remembered they both had a
child died in 1921 in church whooshing
the boat died the same here you'd like
my miracle shame Hey
right and we called that church would
buys Eisenhower to take up painting to
ease stress he said now I remember paint
people only said I only paint mountains
and trees because I don't talk back well
Eisenhower disobeyed that and painted a
portrait of mr. Churchill and then they
recalled that they were both as Susan
said the first heads of state to have a
pilot's license well
to the Wellington rope when I crashed
right through 1970
clementines at either the I will plane
or Clementine she Wilin eyes I said well
when I tried to do it
I'm Amy said to me basically either the
flying machine or maybe he said but of
course he in the Philippines later got
his flight when she was back in Seattle
getting John through high school and
then they were both tank exponents
George was the father of the tank Jedi
may called it winching folly until 1917
it changed the tide of the war and Isis
who else in 1920 water I punished in the
army military quarterly that the tank
should be the not the appendage of the
infantry but the advanced guard I was
told by print again I'd be
court-martialed
and they both shared a mutual mentor
Bernard Baruch
we're not baruch helped churchill clean
up his financial portfolio in 1929 in
the crash and he helped major Eisenhower
and the War Department develop his war
mobilization plan which would be used
later and they both chuckle dahu
pal Bernard Baruch before he would
deliver is one of his been typical bits
of advice would always stroked his chin
and then but what Eisenhower liked most
was saying this in thought of Susan but
he had minimal esteem for politicians
but he said Churchill was a soldier he
braved gunfire in four continents and
they both went to Military Academy
Sandhurst and West Point and Churchill
said Michael I was born a soldier and I
will die a soldier
at
st. Paul's the only one to be allowed to
speak besides the archbishop was General
Eisenhower by the way the Queen put him
with the other heads of state and he
came down to the Crypt and speech by the
way he wrote himself on the mighty
Thames that
avenue of history
the mortal remains of Winston Churchill
now move out to water he was a maker of
history the book is closed but I can
hear him now with the poets a sunset an
evening star and one clear call for me
may there be no moaning of the bar when
I set out to see
generalize and I told me 19
67 Gettysburg most moving thing at the
service
it was operation hope not which he had
told Eisenhower about his plans and
wanted the service to end with the
bottle him his favorite anthem which is
American mother entitlement the Battle
Hymn of the Republic I said the third
verse
and I could see the heads of state King
bout in a Belgium present egala Pratt's
Queen Juliana the Netherlands
King Olaf of Norway faces moistened with
memory and gratitude as we all sang out
that third verse he sounded forth the
trumpet that never called retreat his
will goes marching ah
the first time that Eisenhower saw
Church was in Washington December 1941
just after Pearl Harbor in fact we all
know who this two weeks December 21st
after Roosevelt spoke in front of the
joint session
remember yesterday December 7th 1941 a
date that shall live in Anthony two
weeks later
Churchill's at the same rostrum same
joint session and Churchill here
I cannot help but reflect beat up if my
father had been America I'm my mother
English instead of the other way round I
might have got here on my own well they
met at they when they call the executive
office building the old War Department
and look what Mays dies now this he
outlined the whole military strategy
came enemy mother like a politician but
like a four-star general in the highest
rank that Churchill ever made was major
and they had these joint soldiers
officers of British and American and the
British were very condescending I mean
they kept dropping these names of these
you know spots of the Empire and say
mother rather if it isn't in column on
the how do you think rather sticky as
you thinking up the seashells but I
somehow masses feelings with that grin
as wide as Kansas spy and Marshall came
to him
said Eisenhower I have gone through the
general officers list and I've crossed
out everyone who is a glory seeker a
desk pounder a doom monger a blame
shifter and I do it all yourself type
and the only one who's left is you don't
let me down
well the reaction of America was that I
did let him down
because the northern Democratic Party
the New York Times The Washington Post
is outraged when Ike makes a deal with
dark how dare he make a deal with this
crypto-fascist and anti-semite Churchill
came to his defense you see now like
HIPAA
if you cliche one light I am making a
deal with darling one English or
American life right kiss him on the
cheek
May I kiss him on all fortunes and then
there was the Castleman pass as I said
he had his axe had it on his beat first
time the Americans are in their battle
together by themselves
Montgomery food chopper you died no I
mean had no combat expenses no the head
you see Washington is up in arms
demanding that I shall be pulled back
Churchill comes to his defense he says
from Tang Dynasty said well first of all
there was only a - secondly he succeeded
in bringing making the Germans bring
their troops from Russia and he said
finally he accomplished the impossible
working wielding together two nations in
a feud military command nay not two
nations six nations and then it was
Eisner who came to the rescue of
Churchill
sure to admitted Tehran six days hearing
these impossible demands by Marshall
Stalin well Franklin Roosevelt said
quiet smiling and he comes back and
visits as an hour in Algiers I
I meant the end of my tether I'll have
to stay for more than a couple days with
you and he has pneumonia almost dies but
I was Mariner stand back and by two and
a half weeks later George was able to
sit up for a turkey dinner at Christmas
now they have to get together for d-day
and they're going up in a pail and a
train together and churches swirled
slump gloomy so what's what's the
problem we went live we only one
Genworth right then trying to wage a war
with allies what's up
trying to wage a war without allies well
what seems to be the problem we said
your General Patton is the only bull I
know who carries his own china closet
around with them
well we have problems with Montgomery
almighty in defense indomitable in
advance invincible and in victory
insufferable we said the real part of my
a blue is General de Gaulle that's the
real crux I have to bear may the double
cross of Lorraine is it the problem with
General de Gaulle that he seems to think
he's Joan of Arc and my problem like
this that my bishop won't allow me to
burn him
well they have they get together this is
it st. Paul school which Montgomery went
to right near st. Paul's Cathedral and I
have this one of these last beatings and
to assist you because well I cam harden
to the enterprise-c if you by the time
snow flies you have will established
control of normative I will say this is
a most magnificent operation in the last
30 years but if by the time December
[ __ ] you have taken Cherbourg and
controlling the whole Shan River Basin I
will say you are the most magnificent
general in this century and if by some
chance on Christmas Paris the city of
lights
III and I will say you were the greatest
general since Julius Caesar what he did
but there was one problem Churchill
wanted to go on the d-day landing
and Eisenhower exercised the petticoat
ploy
he went to mrs. Georgia who went to
Queen Elizabeth who went to her husband
now you know King George six had a
stutter you know and they called her to
them did did you hear the news with I'm
a-going going with you on the boat we
have a jolly good Jo ha ha ha that was
the end of that I'd had church or didn't
go on the landing
well you had this of course
all the plans I'm not going to talk
about winning in North Africa or illy
because the d-day landing went on and
and the only fight they had was about
Germany Berlin now eyes now saw this
through the prism of US soldier and
Churchill as a statesman I don't know he
first saw a quarter of a million people
killed in taking Berlin and the Soviets
were going to do it
see Eisner like his hero Rath and who
didn't see Richmond as a strategic then
I mean he thought it is he was just
trying to destroy the Confederate Army
he didn't see Richmond as a political
symbol and that's what isin wonder one
destroy the army he was most interested
in his men by the way I have a book
coming out next year called what
President killed a man and 500 other
funny fantastic facts about the
presidents but I'll tell you this who is
the only president there in the $70
casket and it's Eisenhower he didn't
want to buy be buried in any casket more
than what those who died in Normandy
so he thought of his men now Church was
thinking after the war and what would
happen after the war I remember talking
to Harold Macmillan
I'm sorry Woodrow Wilson Center here at
the Smithsonian he came in must have
been idea yeah
1942 and trying to be renewing the war
and III thought when I said I was
missing mr. Chisholm he said me what do
you think about Cromwell what does a
rather aggressive was the Prime Minister
Harold Rama was obsessed push pain but
he never saw the danger of France and
the curious thing was at that time we
lose the war it already gone beyond the
worn was thinking about the Soviet Union
after the war so that's where
Churchill's mind was and as our greedy
stuck I share his reservations but he
should talk to my boss President
Roosevelt
I'm the military commander here now of
course when VE Day happens and then they
have eléctricas call US government falls
apart
they have election and our Election Day
church was in Potsdam and he wakes up in
the mall Niagara dream when I was on an
operating table and these white-coated
attendants hold the sheet over my head
and I knew it was an omen of my defeat
was Churchill on the rocks of his
greatest triumph cos the mountains
Custer
not he goes to repair his wounds in Lake
Como which through moisture I mean
Alexander had given him he gets a letter
it's inviting to speak to a college in
Missouri Westminster so that's a curious
name there's a PS come and aren't you
how he has children he realize this is a
world form you know he tells the story
and this is a story that is told about
Churchill at the order and Franklin who
loses to premier Stalin and his
heartbeats generously desire for peace
and Anthony in the Foreign Service since
you have to say something
we gave they don't believe in to do what
you have to say something to Laura he
gets up setting up the Soviets are
looking at you so he gets something
sister to marshal Stalin conduct of
foreign policy manifested desire for
peace and then away from the microphone
away from the interpreter a piece of
Poland a piece of Czechoslovakia a piece
of Romania
so Churchill comes and truly leads him
at Union Station right here he's late
judge is late and he's this is the
ferdinand magellan the private train and
they have the observation car it's
Alaska and sure and Truman shows him the
USC at which you know mister mr.
Churchill every time the president has
to travel he has to carry United States
seal with them I've just had the feel
changed the
ego used to be facing me hours I've had
a switch to face the olive branches what
do you think and Churchill thinking
speech you'd already written
well mr. grazier with all due respect
I'd like to have the American Eagles
neck on a swivel so it could turn to the
olive branches or to the arrows is a
case now demands Truman was somewhat
taken back to let's have some whiskey
Tory says capital idea and they bring in
Jack Daniels introduced this is not
whiskey it's bourbon and he pulls the
emergency switch at Silver Spring
Maryland and they bring a case of
Johnnie Walker Black
I don't know if that was the difference
or not but there was one line in the
speech that Churchill had witnessed
draft and actually he did sent over the
Truman's woman approved it but the
famous line he's in Springfield Illinois
the train stops quarter of 2:00 in the
morning for refueling churches in a
state with going over years you know map
to Europe he's drawn a black line down
from you know the Baltic States down to
the Trieste him and he he the train stop
he opens the curtain look sir says
Springfield home over Lincoln I don't
whether the ghost of Lincoln inspired he
goes back and writes down a line and the
next day there is in this gymnasium and
Westminster College engine
from Stettin in the Baltic to Trieste in
the Adriatic an Iron Curtain has
descended across the continent of Europe
Prague Warsaw Sophia Tirana Budapest
Bucharest all of these are now
increasingly in the sphere
of Soviet influence who is attacked by
the New York Times attacked by six
senators on the steps of the Capitol say
that he is a threatening World War three
I don't know Roosevelt said he's a war
monger but for what hurt him most of all
Harry Truman disowns a speech and he
said he never looked at it and he goes
to visit Eisenhower at Fort Myers she
like you turned his back on me and he
said well he wants you to do the heavy
lifting
I'm sure he agrees with you and he'll
eventually come around but he has the
left wing of the Democratic Party and he
has he wants you to make the sale and to
sell the people well it didn't have the
acceptance that he wanted but as as I
said Truman did come around and there
was a you know Truman Doctrine and
marshall plan and NATO and of course
their ear
Isner and NATO Churchill's elected again
at 51 first thing he wants to do is to
see Eisenhower goes over there and
General grunther told me the story
they're there and i's not just talking
about you know what we need more troops
more troops and they've had dinner
luncheon and churchill eyes the decanter
of brandy that's standing on the
chest behind Churchill and so Churchill
says he's now like that's a beautiful
credenza is that new he says well no you
look out here what we need is more
troops and they're just not listening to
me there we need more troops and the
countries are not come in solution that
crystal decanter on the top of the
credenza is that water fruit up that
meanwhile grunther is kicking him like
this he told her I was having lunch with
the general grunther and Metropolitan
Government I kept kicking him kicking
like that what do you understand what we
need are more troops we need more troops
that is not listening and they said well
I think what we need is a lifting of the
Spirit Ike and they get the brandishing
the first thing to do is to lift the
spirits
he's like only you can lift the spirits
you go to the capitals of Oslo and
Copenhagen the nave there's no one more
respective in the world the Union and
you will lift the spirits and he did
of course the next time he I'm back is
Churchill his prime minister and eyes
now as a president-elect and he boards
the Queen Mary to go to United States on
New Year's Eve and they're going to stay
at the home president of Bernard Baruch
on Park Avenue
he's president-elect Eisenhower and
they're working out their agenda and
jock Koval is his assistant and as to
Jon Kovel later I met him and he said
he's you said that but will coined the
phrase cold war he said what Tommy Prime
Minister what do you think the Cold War
were in usually well how old you now got
his abortion
she was your my age or maybe even 75 you
will witness the fall of the Iron
Curtain what if he lived to be 75 it
would have died at 73 he in eighteen and
1986 but his reasoning was this he said
the war between Russia against Germany
extended legitimacy of the Commerce
regime and will take the grandchildren
of those who fought before they realize
the falsehood of its promise will they
meet with Eisner and Churchill he sees a
old man in a rush now and he wants a
summit meeting that's a phrase that he
invented summit he wants it and I know
so well he said I the old soldier and I
wait want to wait to see what my
reconnaissance Scouts report before I
commit myself but he did give the
permission to church army Churchill gave
him his permission actually to threaten
and out of mom inst North Korea to bring
Korea to the peace table now in March
5th which is the same day Churchill gave
us our encouraged speech but it was a
what the 1953 Stalin dies and eyes and
iron cables you can go try and do a
summit if you want but then in June he
has a severe stroke of course as I would
have his heart attack two years later
and he doesn't come back until he mean
totally paralyzed but he totally comes
back and they meet December 1953 in
Bermuda and they work out a plan for the
Atoms for Peace which isin our would
later advance and then it comes back in
54 and Eisenhower Churchill tells I know
she should go because France is asking
for aid and deemed on to like
Dunc it's money down the rathole don't
shame troop share and eiszner didn't
he meanwhile in the idea of something is
a real problem with with Dulles you know
what he called Dulles doll dollars
Dulles is he sound like a Methodist
minister who has the same sermon every
Sunday well you see the problem was
Dulles had this idea that in arm and he
was a very strong presbyterian and the
idea of massive retaliation support but
he was jealous of the relationship
between eyes and air and Churchill
because that intimacy he wanted that and
and and generalizing a great respect for
Dulles I remember his saying and along
with your father was there about how the
greatest many of respected were a
Churchill de Gaulle and Dulles and
Marshall and then they come back and
this is now Churchill resigns but he
comes over in 1959 to get his burden
and he gets himself in trouble because
he criticizes Robert each athlete at
Gettysburg the southern newspapers did
not like that
and they go over their ideas which would
come out in Eisenhower's farewell
address the ideas of what bigness how to
bigness the army bigness of corporations
bigness and universities do too stifling
the individual spirit that makes
democracy great and they talked about
that I know that because your father
talked about that and so did your your
brother David
and I'm in law school at that time and
they're talking about you know this is
last trip of Eisenhower to America and I
want to see the Rolls Royces cigar the V
sign my cut classes and they change the
Secret Service changes our routing so I
miss it but it's going to I knew to it
was going to George washing
to call on because church was my
mountains to call in john foster dulles
in just about the last two weeks of a
five and then they went to Andrews Air
Force Base and it was a May Day but cold
more like March but I paid the cab
driver I wanted to go out to see it and
you had people out there like Joe Allsop
Walter Lippman
I mean they wouldn't cross the street to
see eyes but they were there and they
had this mess steel fence and we all
waited and he saw this shambling figure
make his way across the apron
and we start to whittle a cop and he
makes his way one step at a time up the
steps and just as he gets to the top of
the steps the rain stops and pink
horizon lights up the sky and he looks
down at all of us in her farewell to the
land of my mother
god bless you all good night
in 1964 general Eisner comes over for
the 20th anniversary of d-day landing
him d-day landing liberation of Paris he
stops in August and he calls lady
Churchill said Winston up for a visit
now no one knew but he had a severe
stroke not never reported he's a king
Edward the seventh Hospital and
Eisenhower goes in there an heiress
Churchill propped up against the bed his
face blasted with nine decades of
infirmities not unable to speak he sees
his old friend come in at the door and
he takes this tiny pink Trueba cam and
clasps Eisenhower's no words spoken to
old men holding hands to old men sharing
silently
the memories of the two battles they
together fought for the ideals they
mutually cherish eight minutes past no
word spoken to old men holding hands
I've written 30 books but I say that no
one saved Churchill himself could have
written words more poignant more
eloquent than that mute hand clasp
between two nations two leaders and two
friends 14 minutes past no words spoken
to old men holding hands and then
Churchill on class Eisenhower's hat and
gently ways
General Eisenhower removes himself to
the door and there's Anthony Montague
Brown was eight he says you know I just
said goodbye to Winston but you know you
never say farewell to courage
god
thank you very much I still have some
books back there and I know John Andrews
helped me by the way with my book on
Shakespeare and when I got the OBE from
the Queen said I was the only one on
either side of the Atlantic who had
written books of the two greatest
Englishman William Shakespeare and
Winston Churchill and I think it was
said today that the ink that handshake
between those two of the greatest the
last century is reason why the
english-speaking Union should continue
and carry on that spirit I have a
question about the links to which
authors will sometimes go to promote
their titles and what I'm thinking about
in particular is the fact that when you
go to Grosvenor Square in London and
visit the American Embassy you see a
statue of General Eisenhower when you go
to the British Embassy in Washington you
see a memorial to Winston Churchill's
which by the way was erected by the
english-speaking Union in this 1966 how
did you arrange that
well I do what I do have the sculptor
who is a good friend of mine and was on
my birthday and I rot and I got this
thing and I mean it was something long
circular with a kind of knob at the end
very phallic looking and I opened this
up and in front of my dogs what's that
daddy all right well rabble all right I
got a call later it from the sculptor
it's the original cast of the cigar
that's in that yeah that there is ah I
don't know but I'm happy to have that
original cast of the cigar and I think
by the way in these times of political
correct that they didn't in Franklin
Roosevelt they took the cigarette you
know that was the cigarette holder was
part of Franklin Roosevelt but the they
please correct have changed that and
they've taken that out and I think
that's sad but this and I'm very happy
to be here particularly when the
occasion was graced by Susan Eisenhower
I'm very proud that I had the chance one
time to write remarks for General
Eisenhower so I can say that I wrote for
five US presidents but just to say a
couple things about her her grandfather
he if you were in a dark room that
head would light up he had that pink
dome and you could imagine how the
medieval Saints would put halos around
because he had a glow around his head
they would light up a dark room um you
know they all say but geniu like and
yeah his grid of widest cans but let me
tell you in the White House he worked
under him I mean he was a general you
were private and he and you do the
difference I mean there was a you know
no nonsense but you put people in front
of him I mean you put television camera
and funnel and he had this switch right
here and out would come Huck Finn is
painted by Norman Rockwell I mean that
was he had this kind of how he would
light up and I say one story that that
he said and we brought these people into
the White House the little link
co-captains I'm sure you've heard this
story but a Susan but he and he said you
know um there were these two boys
skinny-dipping in in Kansas and the
dark-haired boy the blond hair boy says
in the dark and what would you like to
be if you grow up and the dark-haired
boy said present United States of
America and the dark a boy says the one
near boy would you like to be is that
pitch up the New York Yankees and said
that's America boys you can be anything
you want any dream godless grace your
background should that boy wanted to be
President
nice president became president all
right president Abilene Creamery as for
the one who want to be pitcher for the
Yankees he failed to that was me
James just expecting to ensure my
tell Thomas is correct or not but on
Christmas Day 1941 Churchill and
Roosevelt went to the foundry Methodist
Church in Washington miss a trip to Bill
Clinton and Senator Hillary Clinton
there's a pot they're saying they
weren't they
I think McDonald agreement you know that
when they apply material well I mean
that a plaque that they probably went
there I'll tell you one wonderful story
that Harry Hopkins daughter Diana told
me I with with the President and Nixon
had this rule that anyone who ever lived
in the White House could come back and
Harry Hopkins lived there and his
daughter lived there so they were
neighbors so I invite Diana back one
Sunday it's the only time I was up at
the second floor because I went with
Diana Hopkins and she said it was
Christmas Eve and she was 9 years oh and
I guess was Alonso washing something the
maitre d came in and knocked on the door
the Prime Minister wants to see you she
was scared to death and she put on a
robe and went up to the Monroe bedroom
where I Churchill was and even I'm just
a lonely old grandfather on Christmas
Eve and I wanted a little girl to hug
some other questions here yes well you
know interesting thing about the heads
forums as anyone here go to Williams
College now the oldest
baseball game is Wayne's amorous 1857
before the football game and the reason
happened was a woman came back to visit
her cousins in Williamstown and she said
well everyone's smart people in Oxford
and Cambridge they wear colors and so
well they'd have any colours so she went
to a dressmaker and the only thing they
could get was purple and she's where
that's what my father races at Saratoga
with and of course it was Jenny Jerome
for his president colors on football
teams but they were from Schenectady and
Troy she was born in Brooklyn Brooklyn
Heights Jenny's room was I wrote the did
the genealogy for I'm a member of the
society Cincinnati and I did
Churchill's ancestry he was descended
from the mother of the mother of Rebecca
of Aurora Murray who married Jerome was
lieutenant Reuben Murray of the
Continental Army
and so Churchill was a member of the
Society of Cincinnati through the jerome
side any of yes
how civilization was civilization was
stayed by the fact that he got a taxicab
to visit Barnard you may want to tell
the people well he was so used to it
this happens to me I know those of you
are in London you look the wrong way and
he looked wrong way and got knocked out
I was question like a blueberry but one
of the things that you don't say I mean
the two differences between us now
Churchill up
Churchill was confrontational Eisenhower
collegial Churchill in the cabinet year
first among many and you're not that
secure cabinet our creatures of the
President and yet Eisenhower his style
he would say to someone now what you're
really saying is this now I understand
what you really want to do is this and
after he was thanked for his advice and
you read on the agenda that's we won
during the first place Eisenhower was
that whereas Churchill would bully as
your would his idea was to bully a
person and if a person didn't stand up
you know respect for it so there there
are two different types and actually you
know I mean with the cabinet you're much
more like a tiger and then you gotta you
know keep on the tire or you're going to
eat you up I mean the cabin de they're
much more competitive than there were
different styles isin are you know
really food was fuel I mean he though he
made a wonderful vegetable soup and
loved to do that he remember you have
the recipe don't you Susan well but you
know for I Churchill would just eat I
mean you know I mean he had big three
times a day and he would have his
branding hammers of course Eisner said
on the cigar is that actually he he lit
more matches sometimes as many is
as they did cigars sometimes but he you
know eyes and I would have maybe an you
know nurse's scotch for dinner and their
different styles of eating and food but
they were too we were fortunate to have
two great leaders and and I think their
friendship and that's why I wrote the
book people written about Roosevelt and
Churchill when they haven't written
about Churchill and Eisenhower any other
question we were just mentioning
something that might be a good note
about likes to conclude because in fact
we have food and drink guts and James
has volunteered
like that and we like to thank all of
you for coming we like to thank
Washington club for hosting this event
Susan Eisenhower for introducing our
distinguished speaker thank you very
much
James Humes briefly served in
Eisenhower's White House and was awarded
the Order of the British Empire by Queen
Elizabeth in 1994 Eisenhower and
Churchill the partnership that saved the
world is published by forum visit prima
forum dot-com to get more information